- For me it was huge
surprise when you say to me,
"I have to know James."
Because you know, James
is Hollywood actor.
So how is he connected to
performance in any way?
And then I met him and
I was very surprised.
James, when we meet, that
you knew about performance.
- There is an incredible difference
between acting and performing.
Both of you talk very loud.
Both of you are very present.
You are a very performance-driven actor.
And you are a very theatrical performer.
I basically said, "James,
you have to meet Marina
"to understand that it's
completely the opposite
"of what you are doing."
- It's true on one level,
but this is also true on another
level when you really act.
And you get into this
character in such a deep level
that you become the character.
And there's even danger
that you lose yourself,
like your person, your everything.
And performance I can't.
But in acting, you actually have to.
- When I've heard you talk
about your performances,
although you're not playing a character
there is kind of a performance mindset
or something that you go into, right,
where you can do things that normally,
in your life, you're afraid of or
that you don't normally do
or that kind of thing, right?
And that's a different, I think,
a different kind of head space.
- To me, the most interesting is
this new element comes out.
Kind of border between
performance and acting.
What's real; what's not real.
So in a way, that creates new dialogue.
That creates some new
territory to explore.
With theater and acting
you create a distance
which you don't create in performance.
Performance is no distance.
It's like, go to the bones.
But to the theater you can
actually play the character
even as your own self,
but you have the distance.
- Does the kind of documentation become
a consideration in pieces
and that kind of thing?
- Yeah, it used to be documentation.
It used to be photographs,
remaining objects,
it used to be video and film.
I think the new thing
about this exhibition is
it's really about re-performance.
- [Klaus] So it's really
about having a score,
and having a person there for
2 1/2 hours, for one hour,
for eight hours, and it's authorized.
- Normally it would be
just for the opening,
maybe one performance and that's it.
But now will be the
full time, three months.
That's really, I think, revolutionary.
- I think the performances will be present
as if they were a sculpture.
- One of your rules with
Ulay, and I think maybe
for a lot of things you
do, there's no rehearsal.
Is that right?
- [Marina] Yes.
- So, to a certain extent
you've set up a circumstance, but then
the situation itself kind of
imposes itself on you, right?
You don't know exactly what's
going to happen. And...
- Yeah, is new as for me
as the public watching it.
And that's kind of credible fresh
because there's no rehearsal.
But there's another reason
why I can't rehearse.
Because I will never have
that kind of stamina.
Because public give you this extra energy.
If I rehearse any of these pieces,
in half of the piece I
will say, "I can't do it."
I think the same does it when
you really do live acting,
with the front of public theater.
There's something with the public
that gives you this extra thing.
This is going on for three months.
And it's really endurance
kind of experiment.
And actors are not used to this.
And how this time change you because
if you will do something for three months
I don't know if it's acting
anymore; become real life.
- But in many aspects of Marina's shows
are complete experiment.
So I think we are both a bit nervous
and intensely curious
because it's an experiment.
But every experiment you do it
and then you don't know the outcome. So...
- Because in the end they really can say
"Okay, we done it."
But we don't know yet.